so today we come to find out that rob
polinka
okay
finished
seventh
in executive of the year voting
uh your thoughts
uh i understand it i understand why he
finished
seventh because i think lawrence frank
was first lawrence his crosstown council
okay
and i get it i mean i know why
now this this award is based on new
acquisitions i think that's the way they
look at it what have you done not that
hey you put together a great team and
look what they've accomplished it's
pretty much what what did you do new
so what lawrence frank did i guess he
gets credit for this is pretty funny
because he had nothing to do with it uh
he gets credit for bringing in kawhi
leonard and paul george
and you know like players it's not
executives and and sometimes his coaches
and doc rivers was there but kawhi
leonard wanted to play in los angeles he
wanted to play for the clippers
and he wanted paul george to come along
so lawrence frank
was in position he had to make that
happen
basically follow the instructions of
your players
and so for rob polinka lebron james
was not a new acquisition
anthony davis was not a new acquisition
uh
rajon rondo was not a new acquisition
neither was kentavious caldwell pope i
mean it's like like some of these these
parts that have made los angeles
a great team on the verge of winning
their uh winning championship it's not
new so i i can see why they did it uh
it's kind of wrong-headed but that if
you follow that logic you understand why
lawrence frank got it well well it's not
just that i mean it's just it's the
lebron factor you know i mean you know
you get you get lebron
uh to come to your team
you know how how hard is it to to be an
executive when you got lebron like no
nobody really gets credit either as a
coach or an executive when you got
lebron james because
and rightfully so and i don't mean this
to dismiss the contribution to anybody
else and you talked about this we've
been competing when you compete in other
great players throughout history i mean
he is in many respects a coach and gm in
his own right from from his position as
a player i thought the second place
finisher though
uh was 41 total points was my executive
of the year all the reasons you talked
about when the clippers were collapsing
sam presti
it's two different approaches so the
first place winner
uh got the award over the guy that he
traded with right
some would say that fleeced him the guy
still someone said
you know i think there's no question
mike
if they don't if they don't win it next
year
it is one of the biggest steals in nba
history if they don't win it i know
that's unfair but that's the reality you
make this trade because
you're trying to win a championship
but if they come in for coming to la for
two years and then leave
without a championship and all your
picks and your swaps with oklahoma and
your whole food
who still made the playoffs who still
made the playoffs